neben unserer erde existiert
höchstwahrscheinlich auch an zahlreichen
völlig anderen orten leben das war ja
schon öfter thema bei uns denn fest
steht mittlerweile die bausteine des
lebens können fast überall
zusammenkommen warum die theorie der
sogenannten habitablen zone
jetzt also überholt ist und welche
erdrückenden indizien es mittlerweile zu
außerirdischen leben gibt jetzt für euch
zusammengefasst im krieg zum science
fiction herzlich willkommen
die theorie dass das leben auf unserer
erde tatsächlich nur durch einen
einmaligen zufall entstanden sein könnte
wird immer unwahrscheinlicher und die
indizien dazu sind mittlerweile
erdrückend heißt aber auch die theorie
der sogenannten habitablen zonen ist
überholt variationen sind ja die
umlaufbahnen um sterne in denen leben
auf planeten prinzipiell möglich wäre
denn in diesen habitablen zonen wurde
die theorie kann wasser fließen und
wasser ist die grundvoraussetzung
überhaupt verleben also somit darf ein
planet nicht zu nah aber auch nicht zu
weit weg von seinem zentralgestirn sein
denn sowohl dicke gletscher als auch
extreme hitze machen leben dieser
theorie zufolge unmöglich aber wie
gesagt diese theorie wurde von dem us
astronom michael hardt vor 40 jahren
begründet seine theorie beruhte auf
computersimulationen und war
letztendlich ein gedankenexperiment nach
und nach machten forschungsteams
weltweit entdeckung die hartz these
wacken ließen jede einzelne entdeckung
für sich ist super spannend deswegen
jetzt hier für euch im schnelldurchlauf
die vier spannendsten indizien dafür das
leben außerhalb der erde sehr
wahrscheinlich ist platz vier leben in
extremen fangen wir bei unserer erde an
auch hier leben mikroorganismen in
extremen zb bei 122 grad celsius in
heißen quellen und auch das andere
extrem ist möglich selbst hunderte meter
unter dem antarktis gletschereis ist
leben möglich und es wird noch krasser
lange für nicht möglich gehalten aber
dennoch war auch im havarierten
kernreaktoren wie cherno wurde zum
beispiel wachsen pilze und das verrückte
daran die erde selbst hat im laufe ihrer
klimageschichte quasi immer wieder
selbst dafür gesorgt dass sie weiter von
leben gewohnt bleibt studien aus den
geowissenschaften zeigen tatsächlich
dass die erde in gewissem maße ihre
temperatur selbst regulieren kann extrem
kalten zeiten hat sie quasi
entgegengewirkt in den vulkanen
kohlendioxid ausgestoßen haben und sich
die erde dadurch wieder ein stück weiter
erwärmte bei anhaltender trockenheit
dagegen sank gestein weiter ab und nahm
damit co2 mit aus der atmosphäre
die ließ die lufttemperatur dann sinken
als sie diese erkenntnis
vor knapp 25 jahren auf das weltall
projizierten waren sie vom ergebnis
selbst überrascht in unserem
sonnensystem sollte demnach bis zur
umlauf des mars leben möglich sein auch
wenn er selbst alles andere als
lebensfreundlich geht platz 3 entstand
leben auf der völlig überhitzten venus
die theorie zur habitablen zone
innerhalb des weltraums hielt sich wie
gesagt sehr lange aber mittlerweile ist
eigentlich klar das leben theoretisch
auch auf der völlig überhitzten -
entstanden sein könnte denn wer weiß
eventuell besaß sie in einem ganz jungen
zeitalter wasser das mikroorganismen die
grundlage zum leben gab forscherinnen
und forscher halten es für möglich dass
diese dann irgendwann einmal bei einem
meteoriteneinschlag ins all geschleudert
wurden und es wird noch verrückter in
anderen sonnensystemen sind viele
planeten viel näher beieinander so dass
so ein hinüber wechseln von
mikroorganismen durchaus vorstellbar ist
diese könnten dann in nischen am rand
der habitablen zone überleben bis sich
die bedingungen in ihrer ursprünglichen
zone verbessert haben platz zwei leben
auf supererden die entdeckung der
zahlreichen exoplaneten hat
wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
weltweit noch zu einer weiteren
erkenntnis kommen lassen
auch auf den sogenannten supererden ist
leben mit großer wahrscheinlichkeit
möglich sie sind teilweise zehnmal
schwerer als die erde selbst als sie
entstanden sind könnten riesige mengen
an wasserstoff von ihren mutter sternen
übrig geblieben sein
dieses befindet sich in der gashülle der
super erden und könnte bei der
regulierung der temperatur eine
entscheidende rolle spielen denn
wasserstoff ist ein noch größeres
treibhausgas als kohlendioxid summen
könnte die atmosphäre solcher super
irgendwann genug für flüssige ozeane
seien sogar fernab der jupiter bahn eine
ungeheure vorstellung wenn das könnte
bedeuten dass organismen auf solchen
supererden quer durch die galaxie reisen
würden denn selbst ein einzelner planet
ohne stern könnte dann wasser bei
ausreichender hitze aufweisen und damit
die grundlage überhaupt zu leben liefern
platz eins leben im äußeren sonnensystem
und nun lieber ich noch den letzten
wirklich spannenden hinweis dafür dass
die theorie der habitablen zone überholt
ist und zudem ein weiteres indiz für die
existenz
außerirdischen lebens denn mittlerweile
sind einige orte im äußeren sonnensystem
identifiziert an denen biologische
aktivität wahrscheinlich ist nehmen wir
mal die kleineren eis monde des saturns
cassini die raumsonde hat entdeckt dass
das innere von enceladus einer der
größten saturnmondes nicht tiefgefroren
ist obwohl der eysmondt mit minus 190
grad eigentlich tief gefroren sein
müsste stattdessen die überraschende
entdeckung unter der dicken eisschicht 1
37 kilometer tiefe ozean im mittel
tatsächlich zehnmal tiefer als die der
erde der grund dafür sind wohl gezeiten
effekte des saturns diese sorgen dafür
dass ein quasi fester kern in dem eis
existieren würde durchgeknetet wird und
somit im flüssigen zustand bleibt zudem
treten aus rissen in der nähe des
südpols 1000 kilometer hohe dampf
fontänen heraus ihre analyse hat ergeben
dass sie tatsächlich alle zutaten für
leben enthalten stickstoffverbindung wie
methan gut an und pendlern und salze ein
ort also im äußeren sonnensystem an dem
leben durchaus möglich ist genauso
übrigens wie die ice monde des jupiters
die ebenso tief unter ihrem auto cad
verstecken all diese erkenntnisse machen
wieder einmal mehr als deutlich dass wir
eigentlich nichts wissen dass es noch so
unendlich viel in unserem eigenen
sonnensystem zu entdecken gibt und dass
die theorie der habitablen zone viel zu
eng gedacht ist die bausteine des lebens
können stattdessen fast überall
zusammenkommen nur der letzte kleine
schlüssel fehlt der endgültige beweis
proben von außerirdischen mikroben doch
wahrscheinlich ist das nur noch eine
frage der zeit die theorie dass das
leben auf unserer erde tatsächlich nur
durch einen einmaligen zufall entstanden
sein könnte ja die wird damit immer
unwahrscheinlicher hierbei klicks um
halte ich euch natürlich zum thema
außerirdisches leben auf dem laufenden
wenn ihr kein video dazu und auch zu
allen anderen dem verpassen wollt
dadurch mehr hier ein abo aufsaugen
vergesst nicht den
auf die glocke hier geht es weiter mit
außerirdisches leben auf dem mars neue
indizien sehr spannendes video also
nicht verpassen und draufklicken viel
spaß dabei und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
kann